Austin's in Chattanooga hey Austin
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey
what's up so I did a graduated physical
therapy school and my wife and I just
finished the complete guides and money
and so we've got our emergency fund
there are a thousand dollars and we're
about to begin baby step two we have a
hundred and thirty-five thousand dollars
in student loan debt combined so the
question I have about that is about
forty six thousand of that of of my wife
loans are in Parent PLUS loans that are
in my father-in-law's name and they're
really high interest between six and a
half six seven and a half percent so
it's kind of hard for me to think about
paying off the small guys when the
biggest loans are are not in mind that
not an our name and are such high
interest our plan is to get this paid
off in three years but still I'm just
wondering if in fact you should even
consider putting those at the at the top
of the debt snowball or leave them down
at the bottom where they are you should
leave them at the bottom where they are
they're not your loans but we have
agreed to to pay to them I'm talking
about legally they're not your loans
okay and so you know the last thing you
take care of number one but number two
they're the largest loans and you're
going to pay them all so fast the
interest rates almost irrelevant okay I
mean I'm talking about what thirty grand
right but how much of this is Parent
PLUS 46 o 46 okay all right so fifty
thousand bucks and they're at 7 percent
mm-hmm and your other loans are at what
they're between three and a half to five
okay so two percent spread on
de grand you follow me here
yeah thousand dollars a year okay over
would you say three years yeah you're
gonna do three years but it's not gonna
beautiful it's not gonna be a full
thousand dollars a year because you're
not gonna be in debt the whole debt the
whole time so we're having a two
thousand dollar discussion about a
hundred and thirty five thousand dollar
problem yeah yeah it's not a problem
the problem is getting extra income
working like maniacs to get your income
up as fast and as aggressively as you
can good news about Petey is you can
pick up all kinds of side gig stuff and
you need to okay whether it's ER or
whatever it is wherever you've got to go
whatever you got to do to add to your
base pay I mean you probably have fifty
percent to your income but you're going
to be working 80 hours yeah yeah I mean
you got the best part-time job in the
world it's more of your regular job yeah
and you probably land that in
Chattanooga it's a big enough market you
can probably find the work so I can get
here and work exactly and so you're
already on the track so again I don't
want you live like that for very long
but if that turns three years into two
years what I just described yeah then I
would I'd go crazy for two years and get
a year of my life back and the rest of
my life and you know that that changes
the equation we were just discussing on
the interest rate spread even more if
you did that fast
so you're on track but you're you cannot
fix well it's not a math problem as
often as it feels like it is it's more
often a an intensity and a focus problem
than it is a math problem and that's
what we just Illustrated by walking
through your situation get after it dude
you can do this you got this and I'm
here if you need some help you call me
you get a little tired one day you call
me I'll Jack you up let's do it stir it
together man